à dijon procès villemin la voix du
corbeau a retenti ce matin dans la salle
de la cour d'assises mais le mystère
reste entier sur l'identité du délateur
un épisode qui démontre en tout cas que
l' enquête a été décidément bizarrement
conduite comme nous explique notre
envoyé spécial downing verdeilhan
presque au complet aussi nombreux que
les jurés les douze membres du clan
villemin sol marie-ange laroche et
muriel bolle sont absentes à cette
réunion de famille hors du commun
tous se retrouvent aux côtés de
christine jean marie lui les contemple à
travers la vitre de son box le 13e n'est
qu'une voie celle du corbeau pincer
nasillarde inaudible il faut tendre
l'oreille pour comprendre qu'ils parlent
d'un deuxième bâtard dans la famille
tous authentifient la voix comme étant
celle qui les a poursuivies de sa haine
une famille que jean caire a côtoyé
comme journaliste à paris match
j'étais parti pour cinq jours j'y suis
resté cinq mois je ne suis pas un
justicier mais un journaliste
d'investigation
le couple villemin parle de lui comme
étant son détective
quand jean pierre nous a fait part de la
déposition de muriel nous avons eu la
sensation de voir grégory partir avec
laroche reconnaît christine caire lui se
présente comme étant celui qui plusieurs
fois à dissuader jean-marie de passer à
l'acte j'ai alerté le juge lambert dit
il
c'était 14 jours avant l'assassinât de
la roche et le journaliste de laisser
entendre à la barre que son enquête le
ramenait souvent sur la piste de la
roche
un corbeau non identifiés par moult
experts baisser les introuvables le
matin et qu'on retrouve en début
d'après-midi un magistrat instructeur et
des enquêteurs qui ne prennent pas au
sérieux des menaces de mort un
journaliste qui se mue en détective et
en témoin à charge
derrière ce procès se profile un autre
enjeu un examen de conscience générale